bienvenue dans paf pas vous le savez
c'est cette émission débat de
l'actualité aujourd'hui nous traiterons
de trois grands thèmes nous reviendrons
évidemment sur les élections
départementales ce qu'on a bien compris
ce qu'on a bien analysé le vote des
français puis la france est désormais
non plus coupés en deux comme l'avait
été pendant toute la vème république
mais on 3 quelles conséquences sur la
vie politique on parlera aussi de du
projet de loi sur la sécurité jusqu'où
sommes nous prêts à sacrifier nos
libertés pour lutter contre le
terrorisme florence père cas d'échec est
avocate à bosser beaucoup sur cette loi
elle nous dira qu'elles sont sans les
les tenants et les aboutissants et puis
et puis on parlera de football le
mondial au qatar alors c'est que michel
platini vient d'être élu président de
l'uefa il est l'un de ceux qui ont voté
pour l'organisation du mondial au qatar
mais aujourd'hui même ceux qui ont voté
pour se demande si c'est une bonne idée
de faire jouer ce mondial en hiver alors
la question se pose est-ce que c'est le
règne de l'argent ou est-ce que après
tout un pays qui a les moyens
d'organiser une compétition comme celle
là a le droit ou non de le faire on en
parlera avec justement florence merck
avait choqué bonjour on chanta trice
avocate au barreau de versailles et vous
avez jeudi beaucoup travaillé pour nous
mais là je vais préparer un petit
best-of étudier le dopage et doit vous
êtes la seule femme aujourd'hui je vais
essayer d'apporter les couleurs dans le
ciel donc voilà la parité qu'on va me
quand même établi avec vous accordez
vous en faire la valise bonjour bonjour
cet éditeur est né avec un nouveau un
nouveau livre dernier livre à pas vous
hein c'est pas parce qu'il s'appelle la
rascasse avant la bouillabaisse qui est
un polar dont polar marseillais enfin
l'auteur et martial bouillabaisse pas
mal à marseille au brésil on voyage
beaucoup et ça c'est à dire non mustapha
allaoui bonjour bonjour ça va bien ça va
très bien
traître a mis les moyens il ya toujours
beaucoup de travail patrice mais ça
baisse ça va bien en asie pareil
joly yves madec des templiers oui
comment ça va eh ben ça va bien ça fait
huit siècles que ça dure donc voilà
et là je suis ravie et honorée
d'accueillir stéphane rousseau bonjour
vous êtes de jeu reflets ce professeur
de droit à l'université de droit de
versailles saint quentin vous admire de
droit public et de science politique
vous avez été doyen de cette faculté
donc vous éclairer notamment enfin quand
on va parler départementale mais aussi
sur d autres sujets et j'espère bien que
vous m'éclairer aussi
bien sur une formule à personne mais
peut-être avant d'aborder ces sujets il
faut qu'on revienne quand même sur sept
ce crash de l'a320 on a appris
aujourd'hui que c'était le copilote qui
était en dépression et et qui arrivent
et qui sacrifie 149 personnes avaient
fui ce bien c'est quand même le le le
plus grand tueur en série je pense de
l'histoire est tout
ce qu'il ya eu plusieurs choses assez
frappante de devenir le mult la
médiatisation de cette affaire la prise
de parole des politiques qu'est ce qui
vous a frappé là dedans jambes ce qui
m'a frappé c'est de la présence de
nouveaux porte parole au ministère de
l'intérieur françois hollande qui
promeut
omniprésent et qui est là qui prend la
parole dès qu'il ya une victime quelque
part il est là pour nous donner des
nouvelles je ne sais pas du tout l'image
que je me faisais du rôle d'un président
de la république s'associe à ces curieux
c'est sûr
sur activité dans la compassion et
l'émotivité
la tâche est immense
oui
mais donc c'est assez curieux et puis
après ce qui m'étonne c'est que c'est
bien évidemment rip cet accident mais
l'avion se serait écrasé de l'autre côté
des alpes oui en allemagne le monde s'en
serait foutu mais en tout cas ça aurait
pas fait le même bruit enfin m non ici
parce que très honnêtement j'ai dit ce
boeing s'écrase et en italie c'est que
ça n'avait pas d'importance pour nous on
aurait fait deux minutes dans les
journaux télévisés et là on en parle
toute la journée toute la journée toute
la journée c'était assez incroyable
c'est ce petit déplacement géographique
fait qui fait que l'on ne parle plus que
de ça c'est bien pour le front national
parce que du coup on ne parle plus du
front national pendant deux jours mais
cela mise à part et la caisse qui le
plus flippant j'allais dire votre avis
est-ce que si on avait pris c'était une
panne technique ou est ce le fait qu'on
puisse monter dans un avion à fric avec
un pilote qui est qui a des problèmes
psychologiques que c'est plutôt
rassurant parce que statistiquement les
musées mais qu'on a assez peu de chance
de tomber sur un pilote de ligne
suicidaire mais donc voilà c'est un
un horrible fait divers accidents mais
ça vous a frappé
pas frapper mais ce qui m'a pas non plus
amusé mais les journalistes se sont
sentis obligés de avant qu'on sache le
fin mot de l'histoire de rappeler que
les transports aérien et est le mode de
transport le plus sûr du monde
statistiquement que tu sais il ya
toujours ce ce décalage entre la passion
l'émotion et puis un espèce de rappel à
la raison qu'en disant aux gens mais
continue à prendre l'avion parce que
c'est transport le plus sûr du monde moi
ça me rassure - j'aurais préféré à la
limite que ce soit un problème technique
plutôt que de tomber sur un sur un
dingue dans le cockpit parce que je n'ai
décelé un dingue ça me semble plus
compliqué que de déceler un problème
technique moi aussi je suis moi j'irai
jusqu'à jusqu à savoir jusqu'à quel
point on peut savoir dans cette affaire
ce qui s'est passé mais au moins avoir
une connaissance que c'était un probable
suicide comme ça a été évoqué moi ce qui
m'a vraiment le plus frappé c'est ça va
probablement rejoindre le thème qu'on va
évoquer tous à l'heure sur la la notion
de sécurité et la notion de liberté
c'est à dire qu'en fait on a tellement
sécuriser les cockpits que finalement le
mec s'est retrouvé enfin seulement il a
vraiment le louvre et on n'a pas pris
co2 il y avait tellement mon alors moi
ce qui me frappe c'est qu'il ya
tellement de monde d'un côté mais qu'ils
allaient périr et une personne seule
isolée qui l as permettre d'aller créer
tous les autres donc cette espèce
d'intérêt personnel qu'il avait lui son
intérêt personnel étant probablement de
mettre fin à sa vie et l'intérêt général
qui était de sauver la peau de tous et
c'est cette voie là c'est cette distance
que j'ai eu tout de suite c'est il est
tout seul il a un intérêt particulier y
scratch tout le monde est par contre on
a voulu ça au nom de la sécurité
générale est simplement très dans la
daurade et l'inca big blind otage tout
ça qui m'a frappé mais en même temps ce
qui a frappé
mon avis beaucoup plus les gens c'est
surtout la montagne mais pour le coup
c'est ces redoutables et pas les prises
de position politiques parce que là je
pense je pense que pour le coup
effectivement ça permet d'alimenter
beaucoup de choses sur les télés mais je
crois que c'est pas le sujet de savoir
si le chef de l'état a pris la parole au
moment où pas au bon moment car corps et
on dit ça n'a pas été le cas
si j'avais été d'un côté d'une frontière
plutôt qu'une autre après tout oui s'il
avait été italien et s'était passé de
l'autre côté de la frontière alors on
aurait été concernés en tant qu'italien
parce que serait tourné en boucle sur
les chaînes italiennes mais il ya aussi
toute la solidarité française ses terres
les gens les habitants tout ce qu'on
aime qu'on me cite et leurs jolies qu on
essaie de faire la mécanique parfaite je
sais bien c'est une bonne chose la
sécurité dans l'aviation c'est une
évidence aujourd'hui la mécanique
humaine elle elle ne sera jamais
parfaite c'était une bonne complaisance
de france oui je pense que mustapha a
mis le doigt sur un sur une vraie
problématique ont pas retrouvé le ballon
a ses qualités et ses principes à force
de vouloir sécuriser un peu celle
appliquée et comment on la met les
crimes je reviendrai dessus sur youtube
et puis le deuxième de deuxième
observation c'est ce qui m'a un peu
amusé aussi c'est les médias doivent
remplir l'auteur
scénario qu'il ya eu des tas de
scénarios qui se sont développés qui
était faux et maintenant qu'on a un
scénario suicide on ad'autres
j'entendais en espagne des des médias
qui donnait des scénarios différents sur
suicide terrorisme et on continue à
délirer alors qu'à une enquête qu'il
entendait hier j'entendais à la radio on
ne connaît pas la nationalité des
pilotes mais il parlait allemand entre
eux
mais c'est vrai que normande c'est
tellement rien que et comme les chaînes
d'info en continu son objet de fournir
de l'événement la minute évidemment on
dit tout et n'importe quand avec une
toute petite affaire enfin l'outil
d'affaires pas pour les victimes mais
c'est celle de cet enseignant
pédophile alors rapproche les deux parce
que le copilote on avait en effet on
savait qu'il avait eu des problèmes
psychologiques ou psychiatriques
le cet enseignant on savait aussi qu'il
avait il avait déjà été condamné fin là
aussi ça posera un problème comment ça
se fait que l'éducation nationale laisse
passer ça non là je crois qu'il est
d'accord il a été condamné en 2008 il a
été condamné à six mois d'emprisonnement
avec sursis il n'y a pas eu
d'interdiction d'exercer parce que le
juge judiciaire peut prononcer une
interdiction d'exercer sa profession et
ça n'a pas été prononcé et dès lors que
ça pas été prononcé il a quand même un
casier c'est vrai qu'il ya effectivement
un problème au niveau de l'éducation
nationale puisqu'on est quand même sens
et on peut vérifier
les casiers et donc il a continué à
exercer normalement parce qu'il n'a pas
alors est ce qu'il ya une erreur en 2008
dans le cadre de son jugement on atteint
là et il n'a pas été interdit donc il a
continué et je crois que l'usagé aussi
souvent en cours dans l'éducation
nationale c'est que quand un enseignant
davis
et un peu pris dans des faits délictueux
lesquels le liant moyen de s'en séparer
c'est de le muter et donc
l'audi est donc en cinq minutes bien
évidemment on dit pas pourquoi on lutte
parce que sinon personne ici n'a rien
donc voilà c'est des gens qui passent
leur temps à se balader d'une école à
une autre et à chaque fois le type à
rumeurs bâti on a un nouveau prof on a
un nouveau directeur
les aubois oui il était à marseille le
voilà à paris enfin je veux dire et peu
importe puisque si on disait ben oui il
vient parce que il va même un peu trop
les petits garçons et petites filles
tous les médias black keys est sympa on
n'en veut pas voilà comment c'est pas
vous dire on prend et même si une
mutation géographique classique
on va ça fait un peu le lien avec le
débat beaudry on n'arrête pas de dire
que tout on est tous fichés qu'on sait
tous et s'inquiétant pas leur laisser
cette année l'un des problèmes parce
qu'on voit bien que il ya en effet on
est probablement tous fichiers
surveillés mais que les plus crapuleux
raison vrai qu'outre des autres c'est
ainsi la problématique du de l'emploi à
vie dans la fonction publique où on voit
bien que malheureusement un problème
quand même je suis désolé aperture ou il
ya vraiment un individu qui pose
problème on ne met pas à la porte
d'entrée on mettrait dehors
immédiatement dans la fonction publique
on n'est pas la porte on mute en
transiger puis il ya un plein jour par
les contrôles de bonheur de voir que
c'est pas tout à fait faux de dépasser
les angles et
on met on met à la porte or ça se voit
pas beaucoup c'est pas si fréquent que
cela sur la masse des halles en public
mais je vous rassure
ses
côtés une faute qui n'a rien à voir avec
avec le l'emploi pour lequel les
fonctionnaires sont employés à la faute
des tâches à faute détachable volaille
reste et puis et puis et puis à la faute
disciplinaire un peu tout ça existe
quand même alors pour vous abordé le
thème des départementales on va rester
c'est nationale puisque on est en est le
vote du deuxième tour n'a pas encore eu
lieu
est-ce que
finalement on a bien vu ce qui s'est
passé au premier tour gd par là qu'on
était un peu minimisé par les sondages
et des erreurs des sondages et les
commentaires se sont faits par rapport
aux sondages est peut-être plus par
rapport à ce qu'est la réalité du vote
mais enfin c'est presque comme
d'habitude maintenant les soirs
d'élection on compare par rapport à ce
que disaient les sondages et on confond
donc la démocratie d'opinion et la
démocratie d'élections ce qui fait la
décision jusqu'à preuve du contraire
c'est le corps électoral ne sont pas les
instituts de sondage les instituts de
sondages vont exercer un travail qui
n'est pas si évident que cela j'allais
dire même parfois un travail qui n'est
pas si nette que cela
sur cette élection là c'était fin
c'était extrêmement compliquée puisque
les circonscriptions avait été remodelée
donc impossible de se caler sur ce qui
se passait jusqu'à présent puisque les
voilà les cantons ont été modifiés et
puis de surcroît
c'est 4000 en réalité 4000 élections
locales avec 4000 personnes
est bon très compliqué avec une
géographie politique
quasi illisible je sais pas si vous avez
vu les vous avez vu les les commentaires
que suscite la classification opéré par
le ministère de l'intérieur et qui selon
qu'on ne perd une classification ou
l'autre des chefs et notre élément
différent donc les sondages c'est un
c'est un repère mais rien de plus et
c'est vrai que la soirée que nous avons
passée en partie ici d'ailleurs montrait
bien que
la grande surprise en fait c'était celle
des sondages le centre il arrive qu'on
ait à danser le front national entend
alors le front national n'arrive pas en
tête victoire de l'ump et victoire du
parti socialiste tout le monde et tout
le monde était content un mais mais
enfin regardons les choses froidement
c'est un score considérable
un score remarquable pour le front
national ah oui il faudra pelé qui
l'avait je crois un élu on a eu surtout
il y en aura probablement beaucoup plus
ce qu'il ya sur les sur les sondages ne
sont pas s'il faut que ça ce qui là
aussi c'est que les gens corrige les
accents folk les commentaires se sont
fait surtout oui par rapport aux
sondages donc ce qui est assez long mais
je n'ai pas vu la réalité des excuses
c'est ce qu'était le vote c'est que le
sondage sert aussi d' alerte c'est à
dire qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
l'art du front national va être devant
donc ça ça motive les gens qui n'ont pas
envie que le front national soit devant
aller voter et c'est vrai pour pour
plein d'autres choses en dans des
élections peut-être plus locales etc
quand on dit elle intel étant est en
fête du coup ça peut motiver les gens
donc c'est quand même des informations
qui sont très intéressantes il faut pas
acheter le sondage trop vite au goût ça
sert quand même beaucoup je pense ça
c'est non c'était pas une question de
trouver dans l'appréciation qui a été
fait tout le monde a commenté en effet
ah oui le front national n'est pas le
premier parti de france mais il est
quand même 25 26% c'est à dire autant
autant que européenne et dans une
élection qui n'étaient pas forcément
très favorable si j'ai quand même passé
devant le pc un an
ça dépend des coffrets en fait la gauche
par toute la gauche va le ps et ps
les additions les additions qui ont été
faites n'ont pas de sens non pas tant je
vous additionnez des gens qui peuvent
pas se voir
front de gauche parti socialiste et
écolo ça fait 36 autant que à droite
alors à droite qui peuvent pas plus se
voir non plus mais là pour le coup ils
ont quand même mieux joué ça fait trente
six 36 de là paraît-il je lisais ce
matin un espoir pour 2017 cette volonté
de la gauche l'espoir françois hollande
il ya trop bien doit j'ai des chances
d'être au fait non ce retour si city
toute la gauche se regroupent mais enfin
on n'y est pas encore on
ne le dit il et 10g d une chance il n'a
pas vu le nombre de chances que
oui on a toujours des chances deux
cascades on le sait qu'ils pensent déjà
beaucoup dans ces élections est ce que
finalement peu parmi les choses beaucoup
plus simples moi je sais que c'est un
peu un peu compliqué mon histoire de des
sondages qui corrigeait plupart parfois
parce que c'était trop trop importance à
une époque les sondages disaient que le
front national était relativement bas
parce que les gens ne s'exprimait pas à
l'heure des sondages il ya le cv les
guidant l'action alors qu'aujourd'hui la
correction voilà et toute cette
interprétation qu'on peut avoir des
camps et des autres moi j'avais juste
peut-être une réflexion encore une fois
qu'il aurait frappé sur 7 sur cette
élection pour le coup c'est que on
aurait des gens qui sont divisés entre
eux au quelqu'un bat ça donne un
fragmentation du vote auquel cas le
parti socialiste se retrouve très isolée
et très minorés on a un coin qui s'est
rassemblée alors on rassemble des gens
qui sont pas forcément d'accord sur tout
mais qui ont au moins le mérite d'avoir
dit on veut être d'accord ensemble voilà
les autres si sauf que il voulait être
élu chacun dans leur camp au moins la
droite elle se mérite de dire on veut
être rassemblé et puis un front national
qui a dit non seulement on va être on va
être rassemblées mais on est déjà
rassemblé puisque c'est autour d'une
seule personne donc on a un camp
fragmenté et qui fait au total près de
20% un camp qui unit qui fait trente et
un camp qui est alors pour le coup
sur le mode d'une seule famille d'un
seul chef et on a envie d'ordre et où
quelqu'un on vote pour une seule
personne et c'est beaucoup plus clair
voilà les trois thèmes que j'ai vu moi
qui m'ont frappé s'activent en avant les
autres s'est d'abord que pour une
élection qui finalement a été assez peu
de monde sur les précédentes pour les
cantonales 1 le taux d'abstention est
plus faible que d'habitude c'est plutôt
un bon signe enfin plus faible qu'aux
précédentes un mois la sphère privée que
si vous voulez donc voilà un tarif
habituel
à le deuxième point avec le visiblement
on a quand même beaucoup d'électeurs qui
n'ont pas spécialement voter pour les
cantonales mais plutôt pour donner un
signe au national et ça c'est cool et je
dérange alors après les résultats ronde
et discutons penser ce qu'on veut mais
quand même il ya je crois la deux points
qu'il faut noter un moins d'abstention
de à vote qui exprime plutôt une
orientation à l'échelon national plus
qu'à l'échelon départemental et ils
veulent un chef un camp unis une
personnalité le sauveur dont on parle ce
montant de cette taxe et parle pas tendu
et je ne sais pas qui ça sera
moi ce qui m'inquiète beaucoup dans ces
résultats c'est que quoi qu'on dise et
quoi qu'on fasse le front national sans
plantes du maillage territorial
et sur sa très inquiétants parce qu'on a
quand même des arguments qui ont été
développés sur ce dernier mois notamment
à l'encontre des assistants
parlementaires
européens qui ne faut pas les pieds à
bruxelles donc ils sont quand même pas
très très haut niveau des valeurs sa
commune ce choc un peu de choses sur des
candidats qui se sont fait attraper ya
peu près 500 candidats avec des propos
racistes très avéré tout se dit contre
le front national les relations avec la
russie enfin bon il ya des tas de choses
qui se disent contre le front national
de manière très objective
et mais quoi qu'on fasse quoi qu'on dise
ça nous touche manifestement pas en tout
cas ceux qui votent front national parce
que quoi qu'il arrive ils vont aller
voter front national on retrouve de tout
je pense qu'on trouve des gens hyper
raciste et puis on trouve des gens qui
ont envie de faire exploser le système
lion vie voilà il donc ce qui m'inquiète
c'est que quoi qu'on dise de raisonnable
d'objectifs de réel ça n'a pas d'impact
c'est bon ça fait monter ça peut faire
monter les basses oui enfin ça parce
qu'on veut mais ce que je vois là est ce
que le mini par exemple
ça favorise la banalisation des vents a
fait mal mais je trouve que c'est une
absence de courage d'une lâcheté
politique c'est la politique niveau zéro
pour moi le nom si si si non mais faut
arrêter de dire que le front national et
enfin moi c'est mon avis mais de dire
que le front national est un parti
politique comme les autres ce n'est pas
un parti politique
a besoin c'est mon avis
voilà qui n'est pas interdit les com
zones et je suis et je pense que les
partis politiques républicains et
démocratiques doivent appeler à voter
pour des partis républicains et
démocratiques et je suis personnellement
je trouve affligeant c'est quand on dit
que c'est une faute morale de dire le
ni-ni je suis d'accord mais supprimons
les partis politiques et
unissons nous tous contre le front
national et on revote françois hollande
50 ans ou manuel valls est clair c'est
objectivement est clairement le la
gauche et c'est très habile
politiquement mitterrand l'avait fait
hollande le continue à trouver comme une
idée merveilleuse de faire monter fonds
national pour des pour détruire la laddh
c'est en partie réalisé c'est assez
efficace mais la droite peut enfin un
jour se ravit en disant on va arrêter de
jouer ce jeu débile à chaque fois de
perdre les élections parce que sous
prétexte de beaux sentiments et ses
terrains va pas fait on va pas voter
pour le front national votons pour les
socialistes doit passer son temps à
critiquer les socialistes et dès qu'il
ya une élection bien attendez mais non
mes chers électeurs des socialistes sont
très mauvais mais l'a finalement voté
pour mais les gens deviennent dingues
après on se demande pourquoi ils vont
pas voter
c'est à dire qu'ils sont de dire ils
sont mauvais mais d autres ils sont très
dangereux
et des partenariats des départements où
il ya des alliances ailleurs entre
l'homme de la bonté la gauche au soleil
je pense qu'il ya des arguments contre
le front national on n'a qu'à les
sorties on n'a qu'à le faire mais sortir
effectivement comme tu le disais il ya
deux minutes trois jours avant les
élections du chapeau les histoires
ridicules en sont contrefoutent les
assistant parlementaire du front
national ayew pas
encore peur je sais faire mais c'est
pareil dans tous les partis enfin jeudi
l'absentéisme ne vous parlement européen
alors
à revenir sur la question faut-il
appeler pour le coup à voter socialiste
ou ump contre le le front national donc
le fameux nid moi je pense que florence
a absolument raison c'est un manque de
courage politique en tous les cas il ya
aussi stratégique parce que être partis
politiques et dire que finalement tout
ce qu'on dit n'a pas d'importance donc
on vous demande de ne pas tenir compte
de ce qu'on vous dit de faire parce que
nous on pense que le front national
c'est pas une bonne chose on pense que
éventuellement le parti socialiste n'est
pas une bonne chose et à la gauche en
tout cas c'est sûr l'ump que problème se
pose le parti existe a dit le parti
était bientôt voilà ils se sont
positionnés stratégiquement ça a un sens
parce que moi si je suis dans un parti
politique j'ai envie qu'on m'écoute j'ai
envie je dis pas que je le serai mais
j'ai au moins envie qu'on m'écoute
auquel cas dire neveu paie pas ni pour
l'un ni pour l'autre et moi je ma
consigne c'est de ne pas de vous laisser
faire ce que vous voulez quelque part il
ya un rapport aux politiques qui est
gâchée c'est à dire que à la fois c'est
seulement un courage et en même temps
voilà c'est juste que c'est ma fonction
de vous dire ce que je pense et ce que
je vous demande de faire non mais
d'autant plus que ceux qui sont derrière
le ni-ni 10 de toute manière les
consignes de vote nos électeurs mais
l'ancien portier de 14
ça c'est une tendance politique à suivre
les électeurs plutôt
et sa fragmente l'ump si las vegas pour
un avis mais deux besoin d'un chef élu
front national
lorsqu'ils feront pas le 10 nov
30% des électeurs aujourd'hui cherchent
une autre voie alors que la voix du
front national ne soit pas la bonne soit
mais en tous les cas ce qui se passe
dans l'ensemble des pays occidentaux
aujourd'hui s'y connaît dans le
bipartisme quasiment partout nous y
étions également chez nous jusqu'au
dernier et les deux parties devraient là
et alors la grande problématique à mon
avis est que vous avez beaucoup de
français qui aujourd'hui rejettent le
système qu'il soit socialiste ou ump et
cherche une autre voie malheureusement
la troisième fois qu'il aurait proposé
c'est la voix du front national je suis
parfaitement désolé mais en même temps
qui aujourd'hui va être capable de
pouvoir présenter une troisième fois
crédible qui sortent du système qui a
déçu de tels noms jo depuis 50 ans
mouvement de denis payre là nous
citoyens très bien le père très bien sa
vie n'est pas
aussi bon voire c'est un parti qui
existe depuis un an je vais très bien je
suis allé à ses premières réunions s'ils
veulent poser parfaitement je fais la
promotion mais en même temps il n'existe
pas il exige justement cette ce passage
du bipartisme tripartisme est ce que est
ce que peut penser que ça peut avoir des
conséquences mais probablement pas avant
2017 mais mais est ce qu'on peut penser
qu'il y aura une recomposition après
2017 le tripartisme on l'a connu en 46
mille rien 46
la vème république a été configurée par
les gaullistes précisément pour rejeter
ce tripartisme
toutou dans nos institutions dans notre
système électoral est conçu pour
justement mettre un couvercle très
solide sur cette marmite bouillonnante
alors aujourd'hui sa pause ça pose quand
même des difficultés énormes au regard
du décalage qui existe entre
la géographie politique elle même telle
qu'elle se dessine et d'autre part le
mode de scrutin tel qu'il se pratique
par exemple aux cantonales ou aux
législatives qui est un mode de scrutin
majoritaire
qui
comme on dirait dans lequel tout est
fait pour éviter les triangulaires alors
justement vos risques on a on a ici un
risque de décalage très important et ce
décalage aussi aliments que je pense un
mécontentement et d'incompréhension
que le résultat des élections ne
traduisent pas précisément l'intention
des électeurs est ce que ça veut dire
que d'autres arrivent à une
proportionnelle monsieur peu de temps
j'ai su bien sûr bien sûr le système
proportionnel alors avec mes conneries
les corrections des corrections avec des
corrections à part mais c'est parce que
voyez le grand maître de l'ordre des
templiers fait valoir un argument un
argument qui est toujours la libye pas
de proportionnelle parce que attention
on va retomber dans les combines de la
4ème république mais la proportionnelle
on peut aménager on peut y lire un style
et une dose de scrutin majoritaire en 86
ans qu'elles réussissent alors c'est ce
qui s'est passé et c'est vrai que ça
fonctionne bien terence françois
mitterrand a bien joué parce que mais je
pense que c'est le seul moment où on
peut dire décemment que la gauche a joué
avec le front national là je sais c'est
pas hollande qui fait voter les
électeurs pour le front national jusqu'à
preuve du contraire sarkozy a joué lui
aussi a bien joué avec le front national
il continue à le faire mais en tout cas
cette
tripartition leur qui se dessine il est
quand même pas très nettement établie
parce que regarder
tripartisme ça suppose trois blocs le
blog que je vois sur ma gauche il est
quand même super fissuré jusqu'à présent
mais le tripartisme mais suscite des
questions qu'ils ont qui sont des
questions qui touchent le fond du régime
sur lequel nous vivons c'est à dire
depuis 1958
autrement autres chaussures
l'ex-enseignant 1946 la troisième fois
c'était des communistes oui c'est le
premier parti de france est assez
extraordinaire histoire il faudra quand
même savoir que les discours qui étaient
prononcés à l'époque était à peu près
les mêmes contre le tacle communiste
qu'ils le sont contre le front national
aujourd'hui c'était la peur s'était bel
amalgame c'était y avait l'horrible
destin de ce qui se passait en europe de
l'est avec le mur à l'époque etc etc ne
lui résiste et
entend
cela dit ce qui a ruiné le parti
communiste en france c'est d'avoir cessé
l'union avec le parti socialiste et le
gouvernement
bien sûr qu'il faudra aller jusque là
les communistes 46 étaient comme des
héros de la résistance plus loin c'est
le label qui n'est qu'ils se sont
imposés sur eux mêmes le jeu je vois pas
bien le héros de la résistance du côté
du front national je les cherche c'est
vrai qu'il y avait l'idée d'en tuer
historique oui un peu différent
les positions de thales
aura probablement pas lieu avant les
présidentielles parce que là il ya des
mécaniques qu'elle songe et qui est
changeons pas mais après neuf ans et une
tectonique qui est quand même l an dont
une qui tous les oiseaux et alors ce que
ce que ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
moi j'ai aussi l'impression que quoi
qu'on dise quoi qu'on fasse il ya une
espèce de force d'inertie qui est très
puissante qui est lancée depuis alors
que le front national depuis le milieu
des années 80 élections municipales à
dreux élections européennes en 84 on
voit on voit émerger une nouvelle force
politique qui devient de plus en plus
crédible et on a l'impression que sur
cette lancée que personne ne peut ne
peut rien faire contre il ya une espèce
de sentiment d'impuissance qui est
terrible d'autant plus quand on entend
le sentiment des électeurs qui disent
baffin qui sont pas des fascistes
patenté ni des gros racistes etc mais
qui disent bon bah voilà on a essayé on
a tout essayé on a tout essayé il en
reste une on va voir ce que ça donne
d'autant et cela et on peut être
aggravée par le fait que les partis
politiques traditionnels discours 2010
7,6 en face au front national et aux
autres essences de gagner donc
que la conséquence que nous vivons
aujourd'hui
et a été provoquée par le ratage absolue
de l'émergence d'un centre dans ce pays
on a essayé et manifestants arrivés
vers l'arrivée regardez la gestion avec
la libéralisation qui sert à autre des
comptes non isolée or évidemment que sur
le plan intellectuel la france est à la
recherche d'un centre et comme je suis
un gouverneur
mais ce sont deux n'a pas émergé ou des
résidents bipartisme et aujourd'hui
comme ce bien ne fonctionne pas parce
que les résultats n'ont pas été pendant
et bien en charge d'une troisième voie
est hélas historiquement la position de
la famille le pen est prépondérante
dommage le nul face à face entre huy
de bâton la tribu
medalliance
vrai il faut acheter moi j'ai toujours
dit que le front national rappelle parce
que c'est vrai qu'on passe au deuxième
sujet juste là dessus parce que je lui
ai déjà dit mais je leur dirai aux
joueurs de montrer tout la communication
c'est ça c'est que le front national a
enfermé les partis classiques en disant
que c'était lui-même ps en fait tous
pareils et moi je prône pour le chiche
pour le mps et on y va on y va on ira
enfin une partie de l'ain une part il ne
tente pas forcément florence vrai qu'on
parle des projets sécurité vous avez
regardé ce qu'était ce projet poids est
vrai c'est vrai la question c'est
jusqu'où on était prêts à limiter de
liberté pour lutter contre les théories
mais ce que c'est aussi simple que ça
vous avez un pantalon magnifique mais
coupable
alors je vous ai préparé un petit
best-of parce que comme comme tout
projet de loi c'est un peu indigeste à
lire donc je vais essayer de le rendre
digeste alors cette réforme s'inscrit
dans une longue lignée puisque les
premiers les premiers textes sur la
sécurité date de 1991 et toute une série
puisqu'on a eu 16 textes en vingt ans
les derniers textes sont ceux de 2013
sur la programmation loi de
programmation militaire ensuite 2014 sur
la géolocalisation novembre 2014 sur le
terrorisme et déjà il y avait une
réflexion parce que on a tous les agents
du renseignement qui se trouve en zone
grise depuis des années puisque ils nous
écoutent ils surveillent en totale
illégalité et depuis un an il ya une
réflexion pour légaliser toutes ces
zones grises et faire ensemble en sorte
que les agents du renseignement puissent
intervenir légalement donc cette loi
s'inscrit dans ce mouvement là ça fait
un an qu'elle est en ce projet de loi
était en réflexion ça c'est probablement
accéléré avec les attentats du début de
l'année pour que l'on mette la loi
qu'elle soit présentée au parlement et
donc la loi nous donne sept domaines
d'intervention dans lesquels on peut
mettre en place des
techniques de renseignement il ya deux
domaines nouveaux
qui sont très peu défini et qui mons à
mon sens pose problème les sept domaines
d'intervention très rapidement c'est la
sécurité nationale les intérêts
économiques et scientifiques essentiel
de la france la prévention du terrorisme
la prévention de la reconstitution de
groupements qui ont été dissous la
prévention de la criminalité de la
délinquance organisée et s'ajoutent de
nouveaux domaines un premier domaine
d'intervention sur la protection des
intérêts essentiels de la politique
étrangère et l'exécution des engagements
européens et internationaux de la france
alors ça plus floue que là ça te perds
vague on sait pas très bien ce que cela
recouvre et le deuxième nouveau domaine
d'intervention c'est la prévention des
violences collectives de nature à porter
gravement atteinte à l'appel du budget
alors c'est tout le problème donc ça
c'est un vrai problème
ça met en place dont deux grandes
catégories
techniques de renseignement une première
catégorie dans lequel il ya les
interceptions de données de connexion
donc là c'est en fait l'idée c'est de
pouvoir autoriser les agents du
renseignement de surveiller le flux des
connexions donc là on ne rentrent pas
dans le contenu c'est uniquement on
surveille le flux par exemple on va
demander aux fournisseurs d'accès de
mettre une espèce de boîte noire en
disant voilà je veux surveiller tel site
ou telle manifestation qui va se
produire et vous me donnez tous les flux
qui arrive sur ce site pour que je
puisse faire des croisements et essayer
d'avoir un profil de personnes qui vont
se connecter donc là c'est uniquement
sur les données
il ya également dans le même ordre
d'idées la la la la possibilité de poser
ce qu'on appelle les m16 catchers qui
seront
tracés des logiciels au téléphone qui
font croire au téléphone que sont des
antennes et donc ils peuvent récupérer
les numéros des cartes sim les numéros
des boîtiers et donc avec ça les agents
avec les numéros de carte sim peuvent
arriver à trouver les détenteurs
rêvent-ils ce qu'elle permet de savoir
que quelqu'un s'appelait monsieur
bismuth par allah et puis ensuite pour
le terroriste il ya la possibilité de
consulter en temps réel le flux de
connexion d'une personne donc ça c'est
la première partie puis à une deuxième
partie qui est l'interception du contenu
de ce qu'il ya dans les données donc les
interceptions du contenu c'est la
correspondance par voie informatique
c'est la captation de parole et d'image
c'est à dire pouvoir poser des caméras
espions pouvoir poser pouvoir sonorisé
des appartements dévier des véhicules et
voilà exactement la géo localisation des
balises et sert à faire le piratage des
ordinateurs et tout ceci dans le cadre
de du terrorisme on peut le faire sur la
personne qui est suspecté mais aussi
surtout son entourage que son entourage
soit volontairement ou pas
volontairement porteur d'informations
donc c'est là on est un peu donc tout
saisi ces interceptions soit un peu dans
la masse donc les agents du
renseignement devront la loi le prévoit
devront faire une demande d'autorisation
premier ministre là le premier ministre
est l'homme clé alors ça c'est l'homme
clé de cette surveillance assez
techniques de surveillance et comment
asma le juge c'est le premier ministre à
qui on va faire une demande
d'autorisation de surveillance le
premier ministre va devoir consulter une
commission qui a été instaurée qui
remplace l'ancienne commission mais
cette commission là a quand même plus de
pouvoir elle s'appelle la commission
nationale de contrôle des techniques de
renseignement il ya neuf personnes qui
sont issus de l'assemblée nationale du
sénat de la cour de cassation du conseil
d'état plus une personne issue du milieu
de l'informatique quand même un peu un
sachant
le premier ministre consulte cette
commission qui donne un avis positif on
y va négatif si elle rend un avis
négatif est que le premier ministre
passe outre parce que c'est des canaries
et que ce soit 7,6 consultatif comme ce
comité d'entreprise et donc à ce moment
là elle peut émettre une recommandation
si elle a donné un avis négatif et elle
peut même saisir le conseil d'état donc
on a quand même à un contrôle a priori
pas a posteriori mais a priori de cette
commission qui est plus fort que ce que
vous avez ce que ne l'était auparavant
voilà très très rapidement alors moi ce
que je vois dans cette loi sur les
dangers qui peuvent en ressortir c'est
que on a cette tension dont on parlait
justement tout à l'heure sur l'histoire
du cockpit c'est qu'on a une tension
entre la liberté quitte absolue une
valeur absolue qu'est dans la
constitution et la sécurité qui est une
nécessité et donc tout à l'heure je
parlais de principe de proportionnalité
il faut pour pouvoir avoir un bon
équilibre qu'on est à
que ce contrôle de sécurité qu'on impose
aux personnes soit proportionnelle au
but poursuivi est alors est ce que cette
loi respecte ce principe de
proportionnalité le but poursuivi il est
déterminé dans la loi il ya une
définition claire il n'y a pas de
problème sur le but poursuivi les
techniques sont répertoriés pas de souci
elles sont non cadrée en revanche ce que
la loi ne définit pas c'est le lien
entre la menace qu'on a pointé du doigt
dit voilà il ya une menace derrière me
faire considérer la donc il faut qu'il y
ait un lien entre les menaces et la
personne suivent surveiller parce que
sinon on part sur un contrôle de masse
et la loi ne définit pas ce lien entre
entre cette menace et la personne ce qui
permet justement un contrôle de masse
sur un certain nombre de problèmes
ensuite deuxième point c'est qu'il n'y a
rien sur la protection du secret
professionnel des journalistes des
médecins des avocats c'est complètement
en dehors de la loi a lancé un projet
doit peut-être que ça va venir au fur et
à mesure que sa dette voilà un service
d'acide d'agents du renseignement tout
pouvoir puisque c'est eux qui font la
demande au premier ministre qui met en
place les mesures de renseignement c'est
eux qui contrôlent le registre et c'est
eux qui gardent les données donc on a
quelque chose qui est hors contrôle sur
un seul service
et on n'a rien sur le contrôle des
données qui sont gardés certes la cnil
est exclu de la loi alors que c'est son
boulot à la pluie donc on peut les
garder les garder alors il ya des délais
il ya des délais de conservation des
données qui vont de 20 dans à 5 ans en
fonction de ce que l'on garde donc et
puis dernier point l'homme clé je disais
prem's le projet dit ça veut dire que
quand on a quelqu'un avec cette loi avec
certaines zones quand même flou et qui
peuvent être dangereuses tant qu'on a
quelqu'un comme manuel valls ou l'autre
qui sont issus de mou verne manuel valls
qui sont issus d'un gouvernement
démocratique tout va bien mais imaginons
qu'on a un gouvernement qui n'est pas
démocratique et physiques au bal à part
examen pape nomme le premier ministre ça
me sens hyper dangereux avec ses
contrôles de masse possible en l'état à
voir il va y en ait pas
le garant des libertés individuelles
c'est plutôt le juge en principe non oui
jusqu'à présent dans un état de droit le
garant des libertés individuelles c'est
évidemment juge même est alors florence
l'a très bien dit c'est à dire que ça
pose une difficulté mais en même temps
vous
il est inimaginable dans ce secteur du
renseignement alors c'est plutôt du
renseignement intérieur parce qu'à
l'extérieur évidemment nos services
comme on les appelle la presse qu'il
veut un geste surtout hors hors la loi
mais pour le renseignement intérieur en
tout cas on n'imagine pas évidemment que
mais qu'on a un autorité alimente il a
demandé à chacun
ce qui est important et florence l'a
très bien dit c'est que d'une part les
moyens mis en oeuvre soit proportionnée
au but qu'elle poursuive et que d'autre
part existe derrière tout cela un
système de garantie suffisamment robuste
alors il faut dire que ce texte il a au
moins un mérite
il est en lui-même assez faible mais
il a au moins le mérite d'exister mais
ils ramènent dans la sphère de la
légalité des pratiques qui évidemment se
déroulent quotidiennement dont on ne
sait que 0,1 pour cent des chefs de ce
qui se passe mais cela dit c'est vrai
que la grande problématique savoir
jusqu'où nous pouvons limiter nos
libertés pour des raisons de sécurité il
n'y a pas il n'y a pas de réponse à
cette question la liberté ne sont pas
absolues il n'existe pas de liberté
absolue y compris dans un état de droit
où un état démocratique la seule
question à se poser c'est de savoir
jusqu'où on peut il est acceptable à un
moment donné au regard de l'ordre social
mais c'est pas à la loi de définir sa
danse est presque à l'opinion c'est oui
c'est un l'opinion 7 à l'air du temps
c'est nous sommes prêts nous a laissé
presque une question de civilisation
jusqu'où on est prêt et parce qu'ils
gagnent on a l'impression que le plus
beau d'ailleurs très inquiète à locunolé
rarement inquiets peu informés en
réalité mais c'est vrai si on compare ce
que vient de nous décrire florence avec
le patriot act américain qui est née
loin mis en route après les attentats du
11 septembre demeurent on est très loin
bien sûr que c'est
gênant cependant c'est vraiment le prix
à payer pour la sécurité de nos sociétés
il faut s'y faire ceci dit moi je me
fais pas du tout à être obligé de me
quasiment à poil avec ma petite
valise quand je dois prendre l'avion je
les fais encore ce week-end c'est aussi
quelqu'un bat pas loin environ les
bouddhas
trouve que c'est une forme d'attentât
méritait aussi donc quelque part quand
je regarde le nom de vigiles qui a
partout aujourd'hui le prix que la
société que on n'investit pas du coup
maintenant dans la recherche dans
l'éducation dans plein de domaines sakho
faramineux le tout ça alors si ce type
de législation permet simplement d'avoir
une un système de sécurité un peu mieux
organisées
nos sociétés et de décharger un petit
peu après le fait qu'on soit venu de se
à poil pour aller passer dès que
sa valise sur les prendre l'avion et bah
tant mieux alors maintenant oui
probablement qu'il va falloir être très
attentif à ne pas aller trop loin mais
encore une fois on est bien bien loin
quand même du patriot act américain
moi ce qui m'a étonné dans le
raisonnement de france c'est de dire que
c'est bien mais que si jamais le
gouvernement n'était plus démocratique
ce serait moins bien mais par définition
si on n'est plus dans une démocratie la
loi nome qui n'a pas
tellement la loi et il avancé avec des
avec des protections simplement il y a
des faiblesses et conteuse et faiblesses
donc on a quelqu'un qui démocratique sa
valise dès lors vous est la plus parler
de lui et c'est le syndicat majoritaire
d'aider des magistrats qui dit on fait
croire que les mesures ne s'appliqueront
qu'aux personnes soupçonnées de
terrorisme or le champ d'application de
cette loi est beaucoup plus large et
c'est vrai que on est quand même frappé
parce qu'il ya des moyens en effet
d'intervention des moyens d'écouté
t'aidera donc on voit bien que qui sont
les victimes via les avocats il ya 13
heures comme ça mais les coulibaly les
passe au travers quand même enfin les
diverses c'est vrai que mes le fassent
ce qu'ils veulent mener des actions
terroristes
ils sont assez rares mais aussi pour
passer au travers de ces faits qu'en
provenance que ça m'inspire c'est que il
ya bien beaucoup d'intelligence il ya
des choses qui sont mises en place
encore une fois c'est le l'idée que
l'intérêt général doit primer sur le
l'individu et en même temps il va y
avoir une telle masse de d'informations
collectées un nombre incalculable de
personnes qui vont être chargés d'aller
chercher de l'information la seule chose
que la question que je me pose c'est qui
va les traiter pour aller à la source de
ces gens qui sont finalement ce qu'on
veut attraper donc c'est juste ça il ya
beaucoup de choses c'est que
l'intelligence beaucoup d'informations
et qui donne la solution je ne distingue
plutôt mieux de former des analystes
informatique que des vigiles en sortie
de grands magasins donc au point je sais
pas d'évolution humaine disait
son algorithme qui trie toutes les
informations reçues et d'ailleurs c'est
dans le cadre du patriot act les bush
disait mais vous n'avez rien à craindre
puisque vous serez espionnés par des
machines a pas des gens alors là j'en
interviendront mais que vraiment une
fille née quand on aura extrait les
données et mais alors évidemment on
s'est aperçu aux états unis de ce point
de vue là que pour quoi gêner on dispose
d'une masse de données considérables et
on sait que en gros l'efficacité du
patriot act si tant est qu'elle ait été
démontrée a plutôt joué du côté des de
la lutte contre les stupéfiants voilà
parce qu on est allé chercher des gens
qui faisait du trafic de stups mais au
regard de tout ce qui concerne le
terrorisme et les salons l'année
bien sûr bien entendu rien autant
d'humour
une très grande besace dans laquelle on
va pouvoir aller piocher avec des
garanties c'est toujours la même le même
principe si vous n'avez rien à vous
reprocher vous n'avez rien à craindre ce
qui est toujours un peu compliqué comme
c'est souvent ce qu'on trouve
l'opinion des gens à l'égard passante de
la vidéosurveillance qui est devenue la
vidéoprotection c'est pas inutile c'est
vrai bon mais les gens vous disent jeu
ça me gêne pas je n'ai rien à me
reprocher mais justement si j'allais moi
je n'ai rien à me reprocher ça me gêne
c'est bon ça me gênerait pas si j'avais
quelque chose tu comprends pas bien
on passe au dernier thème si vous voulez
bien le mondial au qatar donc la coupe
du monde rallions en 2022 l'hiver
puisque il fait chaud l'été c'est vrai
qu'on entend alors beaucoup de choses y
arriver une plainte par exemple 2 contre
20,6 sur le travail forcé des gens qui
préparent les stades il ya un certain
nombre de gens qui ont voté meilleur
pour l'organisation du mondial au qatar
et disent aujourd'hui mais c'est une
erreur il ya eu
de la corruption et des gens qui ont été
payés donc il ya l'idée comme ça que ça
serait le règne du fric de l'argent
et puis et puis de l'autre côté oui à ce
cas ce qu'à payé auprès tout est-ce
qu'il ya que l'europe ou le ou les
grands pays qui ont le droit d'organiser
des manifestations
moi c'est raciste en fait de nommer deux
dalles est vent debout contre le qatar
alors les arabes auraient pas le radar
gagner une coupe du monde de foot pour
pourquoi pas ce qu'il fait chaud chez
eux mais c'est complètement aberrant
comme argument on peut jouer au foot va
s'exercer voilà c'est arables on n'en
veut pas le qatar ça pue c'est pas un
beau pays c'est pas un beau truc
l'argent chaque cécile des arguments qui
ne tiennent pas le coup feu est le seul
véritable argument c'est que ça dynamite
les championnats européens parce que la
date choisie pas bonne en fait c'est
voilà ça c'est un argument à un
professionnel mais mais mais sinon je
sais pas pourquoi le qatar pour
organiser des
jeux d'optique des matchs de foot fan un
peu importe qui est d'accord avec toi
mais pourquoi est ce qu'on découvre
dès l'origine à ce moment là parce qu'il
ya des tas de candidats se soient
l'australie la corée du sud les états
unis qu'ont candidates elles passent ils
peuvent peut être attaqué en disant là
vous changer la date en mettant mois de
décembre alors que ce n'était pas prévu
comme ça initialement dans le passé un
appel d'offres ou de candidature j'ai
pas qu'on s'appelle mais il ya quand
même à peut-être un petit problème jeu
de gens compétents a pris des mauvaises
décisions sans regarder là une carte
météo ça s'est un peu affligeant
quand ça fait rêver la date n'a pas été
fixée suite à aurélie verra
après c'est après qu'il a fait mais il
fait chaud
et annoncé que les quatre grands pays du
football avec beaucoup beaucoup de noms
de vedettes footballistique connu lycée
a dû contribuer ce chemin trim est ce qu
est ce que j ai clé est ce que y'a que
les pays où il ya de grands footballeurs
n'ont le droit quelqu'un
je dis simplement que probablement le
qatar de proposer sa candidature
ils ont envie dans tout cas ça
mais vous pensez que c'est plutôt une
question d'argent
n'oserait dire ça
ça encore une fois c'est tout c'est
d'une hypocrisie parce que quand on
confie les jeux olympiques ou une coupe
du monde d'un grand événement sportif un
pays qui a pas beaucoup d'argent tout le
monde est là à pousser des cris
d'orfraie en disant ça va coûter la peau
des fesses c'est une wii c'est un
scandale le déficit va être démentiel et
puis là on trouve un pays qui demandent
de rien qu'à de l'argent il y en a mais
c'est ridicule à qu'est ce qu'on fait on
arrête le sport on arrête tout on reste
chez nous pour pas être filmés et
écouter et puis on a même pu rien à la
télévision ce qui aurait pu d'événements
ça va être terrible ils ont du pognon
qu'ils organisent un truc ou moins une
dépense de façon intelligente qui est un
grand pays footballistique les gamins
jouent avec des bottes de cancer mais
c'est bien il lutte était par exemple
intelligent que le qatar donne son
argent aux libériens points que lui
derrière par organise la coupe du monde
de football
le même principe est ce que tu pourrais
me donner un petit peu de ton argent
mais avec grand plaisir tout en servant
dans le jeu c'est qu'ils ont annoncé
qu'ils avaient
entendu
justement j'ai pas l'impression qu'il me
concerne pour le coup parce que quand on
parle football
breton patrice patrice quand on parle
football effectivement dans nos clubs on
parle pas de ça donc je me sens pas tout
à fait concernée si on parlait
effectivement de tout ce qui nous
tous qui nous a rattrapés finalement
dans ces affaires c'est à dire le faire
vinci dont on a beaucoup parlé c'est à
dire ce traitement en esclavage pensée
pour les personnes qui travaillent sur
les
la mise en place des édifices voilà le
sujet qui ressortit je crois que c'est
quand même un sujet qui se font qu'on se
doit par don de faire de faire émerger
aussi il ya cette histoire d'argent mais
tout le monde le sait l'argent domine
maintenant le football a maintenant est
ce que c'est encore du football puisque
on est plutôt dans le spectacle que dans
le football donc voilà deux raisons pour
lesquelles je me sens pas tout à fait
c'est la raison pour laquelle je me sens
pas tout à fait concernées et enfin
c'est là où jean charles a complètement
raison c'est que après tout on veut
donner une dimension universelle au foot
après tout qu on place le football et
ses compétitions partout sur la planète
et partout où c'est possible de le faire
la vraie question que je me pose c'est
sur les problèmes de sécurité pour le
coup et là je fais juste une parenthèse
quelque chose qui moi me fait peur pour
le coup sur le plan mondial et qui peut
nous rattraper peut-être même durant cet
événement c'est ce qui se passe au yémen
avec ce conflit absolument terrible et
qui qui avance on parlait de plaques
tectoniques tout à l'heure sur le plan
le calme géographiquement en france mais
sur le plan mondial ce qui se passe avec
la lutte des chiites contre les sunnites
on les retrouve complètement implantée
dans cette région du pays du globe et ça
peut éventuellement se rattraper c'est
juste la réflexion que j'ai c'est pour
ça que je dis que c'est pas très
concerné par cette histoire de football
au qatar sur les dix est ce qu'il n'ya
pas une constante
et on l'a vu avec le rss quand c'est ton
mesuré 16 avec la chine à ce que la
politique se mérite d un événement
sportif c'est une mais c'est une
habitude c'est une habitude et c'est en
ça que ça ne me sens pas spécialement
concernant tant que présente club de
foot amateur voilà
d'autres choses là dessus bah non
j'attends de voir cette compétition avec
impatience et agressions volcan c'est du
mal à 22 dont
les annonceurs qui se frappent les mains
parce que si c'est en hiver les gens
sont plus derrière leur poste de télé
donc il y aura plus de fumée ça
rapportera plus d'argent aujourd'hui
c'est non la seule chose qu'il faudrait
savoir mais ça il y aura sur deux disant
qu'est ce qui est de la corruption pour
l'attribution de ce mondial mais ça on
on y est pas encore et ben voilà on a on
a terminé les trois thèmes à ce qui est
des choses dans l'actualité qui vous ont
qui vous en dehors de ces thèmes là
qu'ils ont interpellé moi j'ai cherché
une bonne nouvelle oui
il ya un champion du monde en titre
avant
le 24 mars a été signé un accord entre
les banques et les compagnies
d'assurance pour le droit à l'oubli des
personnes qui ont eu un cancer et qui
sera guérie et bien sûr ça super parce
que là d'habitude on va remplir ses amis
vous avez suivi des traitements
chimiothérapiques sans que ce soit
déterminé dans le temps et tous ceux qui
avaient eu un cancer décoché oui du coup
ils n'avaient pas leurs prêts et là il
ya un droit à l'oubli qu'être sur
lesquelles se sont engagées compagnies
d'assurance et les banques et au delà
d'un certain certaine durée en fonction
des cancers subi les gens n'auront plus
indiqué si l'on fait des traitements de
chimio pas et je trouve que c'est une
belle avancée et c'est une bonne
nouvelle j'ai un mot peut-être à l'oeil
parce qu'elle vous avez fini mais la
circulation alternée vous avez
une
structure comme d'habitude beaucoup de
voitures mais
c'est
les pauvres cons prennent plein la
gueule parce que je viens
quand on a de l'argent on prend le taxi
ça qu'ils n'ont pas dérangeant coton des
cadres supérieurs on peut décaler un
rendez-vous paris avec deux ans de
retard tout ça n'est pas très grave mais
en revanche quand on est serveur dans un
restaurant canton d
employés et quelque part et qu'on doit
traverser qu'on habite ou fin fond de la
banlieue n'a pas de quoi se payer un
appartement dans les quartiers bobos de
la capitale et qu'on va quand même
bosser là bas la voilà bien par hume
c'est normal c'est polluer tout allait
donc mettre trois heures et demie pour
aller bosser et 3h30 pour en repartir
mais c'est ridicule comme gdf suez pour
un truc j'attends quand vous venez
d'annoncer nom plusieurs fois utilisé
une vieille voiture polluante un père
dont le tout voiture c'est à dire que ce
soit les riches ou les pauvres doivent
absolument accès la capitale par voiture
j'ai su mettre en mots en l'occurrence
on reste en l'occurrence on pensait à
des alternatives oui ma comptabilité à
70 km de son lieu de travail qui aurait
donc tout voiture ça c'est une certitude
sinon je viens après on peut rêver mais
l'aîné transmet l'avenir d'un pardon les
transports en commun ils vont pas venir
demain oui simplement c'est juste que il
faut qu'on avance sur le sujet aussi et
je suis pas persuadé qu'en ayant ce type
de réflexe à chaque fois on puisse pour
le coût avancé c'est ça la de ça il faut
progresser
résultat sur l'impact
il arrive toujours un peu page et
l'information d'abord c'est pas baissé
parce que le temps de la prise de
décision la pollution s'est arrêté donc
on arrête de peu vrai sur les plumes un
nom sinon mais j'aurais aimé que de nous
donner du beau dommage de solar impulse
mais bon là la prochaine fois
non moi jai vue pas de coup de gueule
pas de coup de coeur simplement
l'émission et vue donc
par beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui vous
admirent patrice et donc j'ai ce
privilège d'être celui qui va se lever
pour dire la france entière
bravo et encore merci le rsa menaçable
métal spectateurs je suis porte parole
voilà d'ailleurs une autre à dire une
bonne nouvelle
merci temps de parole merci merci à tous
les cinq
merci beaucoup et stéphane mon sens
j'espère que voilà vous revenez la
musique que vous l'aimiez avait brisé un
record l'émission est terminée on se
retrouve très vite pour un nouveau pas
fait un nouveau commentaire de
l'actualité
bravo